good morning John we're rock it feels
like it's been a really long time since
I heard of hook Brothers video I miss
this I skipped one day and it's like
vlogbrothers withdrawal so I'm gonna
start this video by asking you John what
did you get for Christmas so that I can
then tell you all the things that I got
for Christmas one of them you can see a
sign of but it's not actually there and
what's the sign oh there it is what is
it it's a it's a light and that means
that I can now make videos at nighttime
which is good because in the winter in
Montana nighttime starts at 4:00 John
also got me this book that's about
t-shirts and politics and world trade
but this is a good book to have because
apparently John and I are now in the
t-shirt business and we want to be in
the t-shirt business in a way that does
not help to increase world suck speaking
of t-shirts any of you who got
vlogbrothers dftba nerdfighters t-shirts
for christmas or just bought them for
yourself we want to thieve them we want
to see you wearing them and we may put
them on our website but please send them
to Hank and John and gmail.com with the
shirt in the title of your email what
else did I get
what else Katherine got me this bag it's
a good bag and it was wrapped and I was
like this is really heavy and I
unwrapped it and I was like oh this is a
nice bag but it's really heavy and then
I opened it and inside were all of my
favorite guilty pleasure foods including
fudge rounds of which they're like there
are like only two left this is from my
mom I love them my mom still gets me
toys for Christmas I also love that I
still like getting toys for Christmas
it's nice other guilty pleasure food I
know it says that it's organic and
all-natural and everything why is it a
guilty pleasure well look because it has
62 percent of your daily sodium in it's
like just it's a can of ocean my mom
also got me this and it came with this
and I was like okay so this is and this
you hit him together
and it makes a noise so it's some kind
of musical instrument and then when I
was talking to my mom later I was like
I'm not entirely sure what that thing is
but I like it it's fun and she was like
Hank it's a cheese cutter I was like oh
I thought every time I hit it someone
said a prayer or something it's like a
Tibetan prayer cheese cutter
I got a keychain which I know isn't a
big deal but this first time in our
lives that Katherine I've had a separate
keychain and it also comes with this
which is a key that's been cut into a
bottle opener which is
frickin awesome Katherine got it at an
Etsy store then I got about design
fiction novels which is really all I
want
oh my favorite thing about the lighting
kit is the instruction manual is one
page and it has helpful tips like please
avoid the tumble of the lamps and
finally let me show you a video that
Hank green made about a year ago you
know hang green this guy here my - brain
crack ideas from so far this trip a
housed camera that you can like clamp to
a tree or a pole or something that takes
time lapse pictures of whatever you want
to take time like pictures of yes my
friends I wanted that to exist and now
totally it's the thing I wanted it also
doubles as the nerdiest scepter of all
time the king the king of the Nerds
articulated here but it's a little loose
right now it's okay buddy you're okay
and those are my Christmas presents for
this year 2010 John I want to know all
of what you received a nerf out if you
can tell me as well but I also want to
give you nerdfighters present what do
you like about this I'm pointing at me
out I mean me and John let's say in the
last year in 2010 what is it that you
have most enjoyed we've done a bunch of
different stuff every year we sort of
restructure what we John and I do here
on the vlogbrothers Channel and John and
I are in the midst of talking about that
but the two of us but really it should
be a conversation between all of us tell
us what you like about us and what you
would like us to do with our time and
your time here on this channel we've got
some ideas that I know you will be
excited about but I love ideas and I
hope that you have more and then we can
do more awesome things in 2011 2011 to
11 I'm not sure how to say that I'm
fairly sure that it doesn't matter
though John I will see you on whatever
day you come back